we are back with peacemaker
john cena
all right so
you are
the number one granter of make a wish
650
wishes
[Applause]
thank you
when you
have that kind of openness and
relationship and
sort of
open-heartedness towards kids
you know i've read that you've said
maybe not i'm in my career i want to be
present for kids now you're married
maybe
you know i'm opening up more to the idea
um
where are you at now because i think you
would make like
kind of the world's greatest father
that's a you know that
first of all thank you for the comment
and uh
i really enjoy my life uh i i have been
riding
um a lightning bolt for quite some time
now and
i've been given opportunities to do and
see things that
man i
i didn't even dream of and i had some
pretty lofty dreams
it's it's hard work
it's hard work to balance the time i
need to run
myself correctly it's a hard work to be
the best partner and husband i can be to
my loving wife
it's hard to keep connections with those
in my life that i love
and it's also hard to to put in an
honest day's work
just
i this is just my perspective again
totally not qualified
but i think just because you might be
good at something
is for me is not a strong enough reason
to do that
you have to have
passion for it you have to have a fuel
for it it's like saying to somebody man
you know you're pretty good with your
hands you'd be a great carpenter right
but if i want to be
an actor i'll be an actor and and
just to say to somebody you have a great
interaction with young people that's
that's flattering i i still am flipped
and the reason i love make-a-wish so
much
is because
those aren't like those are those
families wishes like yo you can do
anything you want and make a wishes list
is enormous they literally will do
anything you want i want to kick it with
john cena and go see him wrestle
that is the coolest thing i have ever
heard in my life
because
it means a lot of things
it means one something i'm passionate
about affects people it means two i can
be a vehicle
uh
to to help make a wish come true and it
means three when we engage when the wish
actually happens it's something that
someone wants and and we're the finish
line and the joy on their face and these
are these are uh individuals who are
tougher than i could ever imagine that
are going through a set of circumstances
that i just i can't believe
and they get to just leave all that
stuff at the door
and they get to relax and escape for a
little bit and hang out and we get to
talk i've gotten uh strategy that's the
strategy tips
i should do secret moves
i've been able to single people out in
the crowd i've been able to bring people
in the ring i've been able to encourage
people to create their own wrestling
characters
um i've met uh make-a-wish families
multiple times and seen the the positive
development that just our interactions
had i've
i've received
unbelievably emotional emotionally
moving letters from parents
after some
some very tragic circumstances happen
about what the moment meant to them and
will always mean to them um
make a wish is is
fantastic but all those things
considered um
i i love that i love that joy i love
that connection and and that that's
where i'm at right now and it is
difficult water to tread because
that you know everybody's like well when
i
i just know not now right
i mean
i your insights into
people kids you're so right do you think
you have any insight into why you have
so much self-awareness
well uh
i i've been uh if
honest enough to lean into my failures i
think a lot of times when we get knocked
down it's real easy for us to do this
and um
when you stop and you do this
and that's the only
person to blame through hardship uh
through loss through failure through
embarrassment
um
when you're the problem you gotta lean
into it you gotta salt
and uh
in in solving
some pretty um
some pretty difficult problems
you really got to look at yourself and
and for me the stripping it down to the
core was when i'm able to look at that
guy and be like i'm enough
if we have a conversation and you walk
away being like i don't like him
i i still feel as if i'll project
my full and authentic self to you and if
you don't like me
i'm sorry and that's that's the way it
is i just applaud you for talking about
the failures because it's um i think
that's very real and again very
important for people to hear
it's so debatable
it's not all
it's like
yeah i've had failures i've changed i've
looked at myself i've conquered i know
where i'm at in life i want to help
others i'm not a professional i
like everything about you is really
remarkable i i've always been your
biggest fan but it is really incredible
to sit down and
sense what kind of a true human being
you are with no veneer and amazing
proximity well i mean
except for the suit nobody except for
this giant veneer you have on uh and uh
likewise
these are usually like
four minute things where you got six
questions to answer and it goes by
format it goes by real quick
uh i don't even know
what you're going to use of this because
you have to make your timeline on the
show and i don't care because i'm having
a great time sitting with you talking
and connecting with somebody i admire in
front of a group of strangers that are
bold enough to be here today even if
there's one conversation that doesn't
leave this room because they're going to
edit all this down uh
you know maybe a mother and daughter can
take away a nugget and further their
relationship or maybe some of the
audience can get something or a
cameraman or somebody in the soundboard
booth
you know maybe maybe we can uh help tip
the balance a little bit as someone who
has been cut down to four and six
minutes a lot of my life in these forums
i'm out to break the rules
so i think i appreciate it
[Applause]
[Music]